all of this started with social media
the evidence is every single country
experienced the exact same thing at the
exact same time and the only uh uh
connected Factor would be the Advent of
social media merging in all these
countries what happens is for Facebook
uh at the time and Twitter wasn't really
that prominent but it you know Barack
Obama used Facebook to get elected it
was it helped him get out the youth vote
what happens is as this the platform
gets bigger they need to find a way to
keep people interested in the platform
when they're feed is SL was inundated
with too much content when these
platforms first started you'd see an
update every few seconds and you didn't
care cell phones come out now Facebook
is ubiquitous everyone's on Facebook 247
and you're following more than 300
people your feed becomes
incomprehensible moves too quick so they
create the algorithmic feed where only
shows you some content some of the time
what happens the stuff that gets the
most clicks was related to racism it
actually was related to a couple other
is a couple issues um white National ISM
uh not not entirely but uh you know
right strong nationalist Christian and
white nationalist uh content was was
prominent as well as social justice
content however these big tech companies
you know when you get these Free Speech
individuals in the early days they call
themselves like the Free Speech we of
the Free Speech party on Twitter they
they they look at it very uh
economically they said down on a board
meeting and someone says okay A large
group of people are posting about white
nationalism and a large group of people
are posting about black
nationalism and they go okay well look
advertisers will not buy on your
platform if there's white nationalists
here ban them all advertisers don't care
about black nationalism it's fine what
ends up happening is people have an
option to click on the
most uh I guess bity rage bity content
they can and for these biased reasons
the algorithm algorithm will always
favor anger and Justice over every other
emotion and just as can take the shape
of many things but when you combine it
you end up with police brutality like
things like you mentioned like this
professor but if the tech companies are
like if a white guy is murdered in the
streets and people start defending him
and saying you know white people under
attack oh we we got white supremacists
delete that stuff advertisers will flee
but if it's you know black people
Mexicans Asians or whatever that's
acceptable a bunch of companies started
mass-producing this social media
companies started mass-producing this
and then we see in every single country
country a massive spike in support for
these these issues when it started it
was police brutality which turned into
feminist issues intersectional feminist
issues and now we're into full scale
diversity inclusivity Equity
Etc yeah it's interesting I mean I think
it's hard to say I think social media
was sort of the gasoline to a lot of
underlying cultural tensions that have
been building for a long time the
machine right and I think that's the the
hard thing to dial the clock back on
right like you might be able to say to
people oh here's what happened during
this event with Obama and they might be
able to say oh okay but they won't
forget the fact that they felt this way
for a long time and they'll be
constantly driven by algorithms that
want them to feel divided because that
ultimately sells more than anything else
I I think because they probably figured
that happiness we can't keep people on
the on our platform too long if it's
just happy so let's constantly create
conflict well it's it's sort of it's
It's they don't think about that they
think about what will get someone to
spend more time on the platform they
need posts to look at that and engage
with what do they engage with well on
Facebook actually the top engaged with
uh kind of post is I'm married and had
kids so uh I don't they may have fixed
this but the meme was if you ever had an
important announcement for your friends
and it's like you got a new job where
you're moving start the post off with I
have just gotten married and I'm having
kids okay now that I've said that none
of that's true I'm actually moving hope
to see you guys at the party this
weekend because it'll it'll put that at
the top of their feeds but I don't think
for a lot of these people it was
intentional I think as I described it
people like Jack dorsy he basically
built a big toilet for everyone to sit
on and then he hooked up the pipes from
that toilet into his own mouth so they
buil this machine the machine favors
content that gets clicked the most
here's here's an example YouTube wanted
to uh compete with Netflix YouTube used
to get if if you know uh we go back in
the days of like autotune the news shimo
Yoho Songify they're getting millions of
hits per video all of a sudden the views
start dropping I actually talked with
Google about it and they said Netflix is
is our biggest competitor and I said
Netflix I was like oh you're missing the
big picture here if you think it's
Netflix their view was what are people
watching online it used to be YouTube
now it's Netflix Netflix introduced
streaming everybody signed up they're
getting premium content so YouTube said
we need to get our creators to start
making content that competes with Game
of Thrones so here's the idea if your
video is longer than 10
minutes and people watch it for a long
time that's what we want h attention
rates longer videos then people will
start producing shows like Game of
Thrones what did they get instead Tim
cast IRL how do you produce engaging
long form content video podcasts
vodcasts the problem with that is you
got a massive spattering of
argumentative and you know serious
political issues which generate a wave
of nationalist white nationalist racist
all sorts of content and I'm not saying
only I'm saying it included Everything
YouTube then panics going oh no that's
not what we meant so these companies
don't actually care about what the
content is so long as it's making money
for them and if advertisers will buy on
the platform so they're not thinking
like I want people angry they're saying
tell the algorithm to favor high high
retention rates and long videos what
happens after this parents would give
iPads to their babies this was part of
the elsagate Scandal several years ago
it's like six seven years ago now they
they would give an iPad to their baby
and leave the room they would press play
on finger family at the time it was the
most popular nursery rhyme have you guys
ever heard this one yeah yeah finger
family where are you whatever and it
goes index finger middle finger when the
song ends YouTube's autoplay feature
will load the next video automatically
so the parent puts the the iPad in front
of the baby the song ends another video
plays eventually it starts the algorithm
doesn't actually know what finger family
is
there there were people in India knowing
this was the trend started exploiting
the algorithm by producing extremely
lowquality and freaky videos like uh the
example I have give is the Incredible
Hulk doing ta Chichi with Adolf Hitler
but goodness but it's Hitler's head on a
on a a woman's body with in a bikini and
this is not an
exaggeration what would happen is once
the audio once the parents would play
the video and the video would end it
would just autoplay the next video for
finger family and it just so happened to
be the incred inedible hooking ad off
Hitler but Hitler had boobs and it was
weird freaky stuff they didn't
intentionally make that happen it
happened because all they did was tell
the algorithm to let it go what what
I've argued and I believe this is the
most likely scenario as a baby you don't
know what you're watching so if you're
watching finger family and the next
thing that pops up is Hitler you're just
a baby staring at a screen going but an
adult can see that and go whoa something
is wrong here however
adults aren't immune to this either when
you're watching a video about a criminal
case involving a corrupt cop and you go
man the next video that plays is say
George Floyd or ammed Arbury you go wow
you don't realize you're actually I'm
going to say this I will equate the Amed
Arbury case to Adolf Hitler with a
woman's body doing taichi with the
Incredible Hulk as an adult it falls
into your preconceived notions and it
seems to make sense but the story is
totally fabricated in false everything
people know from the mainstream press
the Amed Arbury case what what who do we
have on the show recently they were like
oh that was the guy who was jogging
right he wasn't jogging that was never
even a legal talking point the courts
they never argued that armed auy was
just jogging they actually conceded he
was a burglary suspect who had been
witnessed and was wanted by the police
for questioning but in the mainstream
media they were saying he was just
jogging that's these are people who live
in the world where they can't recognize
the algorithm is feeding them refu down
their throats and that's why I say the
people running these companies didn't
one day decide let's produce a bunch of
rageful content to make them go insane
no Jack dorsy was like we're the Free
Speech we the Free Speech party then
when the algor algorithms they created
were propping up the most psychotic
nonsensical garbage he took that hose
and shoved it straight down his throat
started absorbing it believing it and
sheded his own brain the people then
running these companies adopted these
views and integrated them back into
their systems exacer ating the problem
here we
are that's so true do you feel like this
is something that people who aren't
involved in alternative media aren't
aware of like if you were a longtime Fox
sort of corporate person would you be as
well versed in Elsa gate and all of this
stuff do you think you you have an
advantage because of the the medium
you're in you mean like the people who
are paying watching cable live in cable
TV world yeah I mean so this this is the
reality of 20 or 30 years ago if someone
went to CNN and said I have a huge story
and they were like we don't want to
cover that that's it never happens no
never hears about it and have a nice day
with the internet some random guy makes
a video and he's like I think Epstein's
doing something you end up with Alex
Jones massive personality generating
Millions outside of the controls of the
deep State I mean look we know about
Mocking Bird we know about how uh
intelligence agents would go to the
press and say Here's an article we wrote
for you sign your name on it not every
journalist and deep State narrative
story is like that most of them aren't
we know they do that the problem now is
the only way to control the narrative is
through extreme censorship and the
problem there is a decentralized press
mechanism like what we have now with
shows like this can see through it call
it out causes problems and they lose
hence Donald Trump is the front
runner do you think where we go I don't
know yeah that's the question I mean
that's my my big question for 2024
really has been who is going to come
come next after this who's going to be
sort of the successor to the Trump
movement because he is such a
personality that's the that's the real
shame with DeSantis it should have been
DeSantis no no I think I think we're
lucky with the sis you think that we
that we lucked out oh we got so lucky in
that he failed yeah absolutely I mean
this guy could have been the AA parent
though no he couldn't have and he and
this is this is the point it's a good
thing he ran so that we all got to see
just how impotent he was politically I
mean the dude can't run a campaign can't
control the staff he lacks can't hire he
can't hire he can't sell he can't he
can't even pitch and so if this guy did
not run and everyone kept praising him
is like this guy's so great and then
2028 comes around and he goes well I'm
here to take over for Donald Trump uh
here are my high heels and here are the
crackpots that I've hired we'd be like
oh crap but he might have learned in the
intervening years he might have got
better you no look look there was can
improve you think people not Rhonda no
stop we we were at um the office
building that we were in for the AWA
caucus was the same building as V's
campaign office for uh de Mo his
headquarters was at a different location
um at for that four caucus night I think
the office we were in was his principal
office we were not in his office there's
a distinction but we were in the same
building and we had to negotiate with
the building's owner so it's not like
you know V get got us anything but we
were in the same space with him he did
help us find it that's that no no doubt
but in one of the rooms they have on
this white board things successful
people do and I just laughed when I saw
it it's like they ask for help you know
they're Missi driven and I'm like these
are things you can't give people okay
I've been in so many corporate meetings
so many Corporate Offices where it's
like here's how to be successful and
they try to teach someone who doesn't
have the X Factor how to have the
xfactor and they don't so when I used to
do fundraising for nonprofits what they
decid Ed was just give everyone the
lowest common denominator training as to
how you pitch someone to donate to your
cause and so they tell everybody keep
your feet spread open with your with
each foot lining up with your shoulders
keep your arms open never cover your
chest never hold a binder over your
chest those are all off-putting bounce
on the balls of your feet and rock back
and forth this is what they tell
everyone to do and here's what you have
to say and how you have to say it and
I'm
like if someone doesn't have the ability
to sell this will not help them right
and if someone does this will hurt them
so I look at Ronda santis totally
useless in other words totally totally
useless what you'd find is they would
tell you probably for legal reasons you
have to say this verbatim yeah right
everybody who went out to fund raise for
every nonprofit I ever worked with would
say whatever they felt like saying and
they would always sign people up and the
people who would always try to do the
pitch would get super angry and be like
why can't I do this I I I've seen people
like Ronda Sanders before okay me and my
buddy got hired uh so I I'll try to
simplify the story me and my buddy
worked for nonprofit they hired a woman
we were both managers she ends up
working underneath me she's brilliant as
soon as she gets trained by me one of
the top fundraisers in the nation she
she goes to another company and says I
want to be a director a position above
me I was trained by one of the nation's
best from this company and they were
like Wow Jobs yours impressive resum
resume speaks multiple language has
training from one of the top fundraisers
in the country and then she immediately
hits me up and says you want to work for
me and I was like wow I am impressed and
so me and my buddy end up saying okay
fine skrew will'll go work for your work
for your office one of her friends me
it's it's it's three of us me my friend
and this guy this guy that she hires is
a friend of vers he doesn't have it he
is the Ronda santz of fundraising we are
both Trump and V gramas Swami of
fundraising and so me and him are
standing there on the street down in
Chicago both of us are sitting there
with like glazed over looks on our faces
half paying attention expending no
energy this guy is doing everything he's
told standing upright balls of his feet
waving to people asking him asking him
asking him he's getting burned out me
and the other guy are sitting there and
then we see the person we go that guy
right there you come over here sell him
instantly this guy freaks out gets
really angry and he was like I don't
understand I'm doing everything I'm told
to do and no one will talk to me and
then I'm watching these guys do nothing
and then just snap their fingers and
someone comes and signs up and I was
like what we have is the ability to
recognize someone who's interested open
willing to talk you're going about it
through the motions that's how I see
Rhonda Sanz he does not have the
abilities you can beg him to please
understand what he's doing wrong and we
tried and all that happens is he doubles
down with a CRA yeah absolutely he has a
crackpot campaign staff what did they
say the media calling it for Trump was
actually Pro Biden and pro Trump and and
and the media's biased for Trump and
it's like you you've lost your minds
we've been warning the whole time since
since desis announced that his campaign
is garbage he has no Carisma he's a he's
failing and when it first starts and
we're polite about it like guys what
what did we say first here on the show I
was like you got to get him speech
training and Charisma training and they
said how dare you and they started
attacking all of us insulting all of us
and now got their minions to attack
everybody Tim you have a you have a good
gift naturally is sales
what I tell people if like if you're
selling something let's say you're
selling real estate you walk in a room
you don't want someone just to bombard
you with your card just because you
don't want someone who was needy and
pushy do the opposite get someone to
like you first be warm and Ron was never
been able to do the opposite he was just
as stiff he came across that way and I
would have told him Ron got to be if you
can't if you don't have it just do the
opposite try to be warm you know you are
correct but I don't think that's the
principal issue I think the principal
issue is that he's a loser and I know
that he he he won his Congressional
races we like the policy he's got he won
in Florida massively I don't give him
credit for all of it I give him credit
for some of it but the re what I what I
mean by loser
is when you're selling something it
doesn't matter if you know what it is it
matters that you sound like you do cuz I
don't know okay if I call a plumber and
I'm like guy my toilet's busted and he
goes well I mean I could probably fix it
I'd have to look at it I'm not you know
I think I could do it I'll be like okay
well you know let me give you a call
back then I call Trump plumbing and he
goes listen we're the best plumbers
we're going to come in fix it five
minutes easy cheap no one's better than
us everyone agrees well I'm going to be
like I want that guy get in here he cuz
he's at least just sound confident and I
think you might show up you know and you
know Gary Johnson exemplifies this when
he said and what is Aleppo everyone
knows the Aleppo moment that is loser
talk and I'm trying I'm kind of trying
to be in a dick but not really I've I've
often said if Donald Trump was
confronted with a with a with a subject
matter he didn't know about you so
imagine Trump's being interviewed and
someone says yes but as president how
will you H how will you handle Lucen
dando Trump would go look you know
people have been talking about Luc
andando but the economy is what matters
to the American people so we're going to
do that it's a it's a gibberish what I
made up but Trump would deflect by
saying I'm not going to sit here and
talk about an issue like that when the
American people are concerned about
their jobs he Gary Johnson goes what's
that and everyone's like he doesn't know
what Aleppo is I mean people are dying
here this country is being blown to
Smither and so when you look at Ronda
santis
listen if I'm going to sell you
anything who are you g to buy from the
guy who says well I'm here to offer you
a drink of this uh delicious spin drift
lemon drink you'd be like okay or the
guy who walks in and says this is the
most delicious drink I've ever had but
I'll tell you what I'll give you a
little bit you got to pay you're like oh
what's this all about confidence
Charisma Ron does not have it you can't
give him it we tried all he did was get
a bunch like you know you know what I
feel like with the sandis people I feel
like it's High School really like high
school Donald Trump is like he's not
necessarily a football player he's he's
like kind of the bigger guy who hangs
out with a bunch of he's tall he's he's
he's chunky but he's he's he's the
jokester he's funny people kind of like
him and he's the guy that everybody
likes kind of there the guy in the
middle who got along with the Rockers
and the sports people yeah everybody
liked him and and and he's kind of a
dick sometimes but he always he'll rib
on you and say I'm just kidding and
he'll give you a shove and Ronda santis
is the nerdy kid in the glasses with his
dorky friends being like you know why
don't people listen to us we are smarter
than they are people are so stupid I bet
if we tell them they're stupid they'll
listen to us yeah good luck with that to
santis congratulations I feel like VI is
the guy who was just like what no I'm
not paying any attention to any of these
people g go do my own thing that's what
he seems like to me the is
like hang he's hanging out with the cool
kids and he's the shorter fast talking
guy you know so when I used to do
nonprofit fundraising two there were two
kinds of guys that made a bunch of money
tall guys and smooth talking guys
Trump's tall guy V smooth talking guy
that's what it is Ron is the nerdy guy
who got fired in 3 days that that's just
the reality of it you know welcome to
politics I feel like V is fun because
then who's the Nikki who is Nikki Nikki
is like like that girl on student
council who really annoying and she's
always talking about something that no
one wants to do and she's always trying
to she's always trying to drop bombs on
foreign countries and like your teachers
really like her but it's hard to explain
to them that like no one else does and
they're like but why don't you just
listen to nck and you're like because
Nikki trying to get everyone to blow up
the balloons for prom yeah but also like
it's a prom that she organized where no
one wants a date that's con inconvenient
for everyone else like she's ultimately
self-c centered but she's passing it off
as like but I'm doing it for you guys
that's Nikki Haley to me that's
interesting yeah thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8:00 p.m. and become a member
over at
timcast.net uncensored membersonly shows
exclusive thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all next
time